and i noticed that
the main character
moves
through four of the six archetypes like
clockwork
what is the yanking concept of the hero
within and how does it work within
storytelling so
so the whole jungian approach
for filmmakers feels like it's a bit of
a catch-all bucket
um where
you know like everybody
likes to put into young gay and young it
was very
dealt with a lot of like
symbols and hidden meanings and things
like that but in the
the most
i think concise and
well constructed
version of this came from a the book
hero within
um by a
person named carolus pearson
who i think i don't think she's alive
anymore this book's
fairly
old but um but you know carol if you're
still with us i apologize
but i think i think she may have passed
on but anyway
but she she was a psychologist
who wrote a book as a self-help book
you know what the idea and it's like the
hero within i think it's like six
archetypes we live by
and and her idea was that
was that
if you can define
yourself
by one of these six
archetypes which was like you know uh
warrior wanderer orphan
martyr
innocent
magician there we go i actually got them
all um so if you so you can kind of
define yourself by one of these
archetypes
you could then say
well i don't want to be a martyr i want
to be a warrior and then she was able to
chart
well how does based on classic
literature how did
stories that had orphans who became or
martyrs who became warriors
what was that journey like and so she
was sort of interestingly extrapolating
from literature
self-help lessons
which is really kind of interesting like
i you know like
most people get into writing
kind of define
you know like i want to be like
you know bruce wayne when i grow up i
want to be like you know whatever you
know you know harry and when harry
mitzvah you know it's like it's like you
start imagining yourself as these
characters she kind of went the other
way she says you know she was kind of
like
you know you can you can learn lessons
from those characters and reimagine
yourself
you know into a different character it
was kind of like an interesting approach
so um
so
for her it was it was a self-help manual
um and
which kind of described
sort of the history of literature and i
think it was like literature and poetry
and um
theater that she was she was pulling her
information from
um
i mean i
tripped upon it
a
friend of mine who's
very gifted writer who
um
who got
kind of uh shafted by one of the
writer's guild strikes you know kind of
like just cut him off at the knees at a
certain point
um but brilliant mind brilliant writer
great insights into storytelling a lot
of a lot of the
the things that i understand about story
came from this ongoing conversation i
had with him his name was gilbert evans
and uh and so very much the
you know a lot of my whole approach to
storytelling was based on this ongoing
conversation gil and i would have back
and forth about oh i just realized this
oh i just realized this and we would
like kind of share this information and
he had stumbled across this book um you
know the
hero within
and
and i i like clearly remember this
conversation and i'm talking about like
1997
1998 you know somewhere around there
where um
where um
gil calls me up and goes i just
discovered this really cool book called
the hero within it's got these six
archetypes and i was looking at some of
the movies that i really like and i
noticed that
the main character
moves
through four of the six archetypes
like
clockwork i was like really so you're
saying yeah it's like act one the main
character is an orphan of some kind
either a figurative orphan or a literal
often orphan so the main character is an
orphan of some kind in act one
act two
they become a wanderer
um
and we'll we'll tie it back to the
central question at some point but act
two they become a wanderer act three in
my four act structure they become a
warrior in act four they become a martyr
it's like wow it's really interesting it
can't possibly be true but it's really
interesting and i started looking at
movies and stories and going oh my god
it is true like every well-constructed
story the main character goes through
these four archetypes like clockwork um
you know and it's it just became like
this it almost became like the
it's like one of the
defining cornerstones of
you know of um
of my whole understanding of story was
that like so many things kind of like
fell into place
as a result of understanding those four
archetypes
even to the point where you know like
one of the earliest
kind of aha moments i had was
talking to an exec at disney um who i
pitched some store i don't remember what
it was anymore i pitched him a story and
he went yeah that was okay but your
story you know didn't answer the
four
central questions
i was like
okay
what what might those four central
questions be
and it's like who's your main character
you know what are they trying to
accomplish who's trying to stop them and
what happens if they fail
right so
so suddenly you went
you know
understanding the archetypes suddenly
start started to shed some light on the
the central question that not central
questions the uh you know the four
questions
of of the film like who's your main
character it's on the orphan what's he
trying to accomplish that's wanderer
right you know who's trying to stop them
right that's warrior because somebody's
trying to stop you you're going to stop
them back that's warrior and what
happens if they fail that's martyr so
it's like suddenly like everything
started folding in on itself
you know that these archetypes started
now relaying relating to you know the
four main questions of uh you know of
your story which just started relating
into the four acts of the
of the structure
that i had you can now start saying oh
well act one
is who's your main character and orphan
now act two right and it's just
everything just started like
like lining up really really neatly as a
result of that
so um
you know i think there's probably all
sorts of reasons that really smart
people know why it works that way i was
just happy that it worked you know it's
like i don't need to understand the
schematic to my microwave to you know
fill up a piece of chicken i'm just
happy it does it when i hit the thought
button so there's probably people out
there with a much more intellectual and
academic understanding of exactly why
this works i'm just happy it does
and i think there's also a school of
thought that you know
in each of these archetypes that we all
possess or all of our characters possess
that there's a dark and a light to them
and and how that could be a hindrance or
helpful in the story to your character's
journey so right um you know you could
say the warrior is is brave but also the
warrior could also start fights and and
and it could cause problems um the
innocent could be uh charming and sweet
but also it could be taken advantage of
you know so there's different things
that yeah absolutely right and that and
that and that actually plays in with uh
the unity of opposites which is like a
whole nother you know part of it you
know that whole idea that that there's
you you want to have a layered character
you want to have characters that that
are not just one-dimensional you can
you know and and those are those are
perfectly fine characters and they live
in perfectly fine stories um where it
starts getting interesting though right
it's the difference between you know
bruce wayne and the in the dark knight
versus luke skywalker and star wars
right so it's it's this
you know you you get a more complex
character but
you know but there there's a caution
that comes with that is that people
sometimes will overly complicate a
character just for the sake of overly
complicating them
and and then the pieces don't hold
together right you want to be able to
you want to be able to like really
understand why a character
does what they do
like
i'm not even necessarily talking about
like anti-heroes or like a good
example because by their very nature
but
but you want to have these layered
complex characters you know walter white
from breaking bad was a brilliantly
complex character
right um you know which was just by
itself like a brilliant
piece of storytelling you know yeah by
vince gilligan the um
the idea how do do you take like i think
even he said like we want to take mr
chips and turn him into scarface
right so that idea of how do you take a
guy who's just a family man and he's
dying of cancer and he's a high school
chemistry teacher and a really really
good guy
and turn him into this
brutal drug lord
right that's a complex character and all
those pieces were kind of there from the
beginning they just like slowly
made themselves known to the the
audience as as the series progressed
right so you don't want to just have
like my character is this right my
character is that there's um
there's a i don't remember who came up
with it but of course it was probably in
conversation with gil evans that that we
started talking about it is
you know is
use the term like accept when
right so like um
woody from toy story you know is
you know is the
you know is the
friendliest
best toy and leader
in the entire history of toys
except when his relationship with andy
gets threatened
right and that's what happens with buzz
lightyear because life throws up and
threatens
woody's relationship with andy now we
see a whole other side of woody so you
can take your main character and say
this is who my character is except when
this thing happens and then that and
that's a trigger to explore another
aspect aspect of the character
and with walter white i think
we start to see him just become this
other person a hundred percent of the
time whereas it slowly starts with the
car wash and then buying the genes and
seeing his son bullied and and you start
to see it bubble out yeah but but it's
not there yet and then finally it's full
on and there's no turning back yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of interesting like uh
just joining on me now it's like another
fantastic movie with complex characters
was uh unforgiven like the the clint
eastwood movie from
okay i don't know is it 20 years ago by
now 30
it's a long time
but yeah a terrific terrific you know
oscar-winning screenplay
but
you know but clint eastwood's character
of
bill or william
money i guess was his name
um
had this horrible past but we don't know
about his horrible past until we see him
in in the present as this kind of
bumbling inept
kind of broken rancher his wife is dead
and
you know and he's losing his
abilities like you know he's trying to
he was like he was trying to shoot and
feel like when he's thinking about going
on this mission to raise some money to
save the farm
you know he tries shooting at some cans
you know you know in the distance with
his pistol and he can't hit him and he
like goes inside his kids are watching
him kind of like unimpressed he goes
inside and grabs a shotgun
because now he can at least hit it with
the shotgun so he's you're seeing this
guy who's like
past his prime
and and it's only as the story
progresses you go oh my god this was the
most notorious killer in the west you
know who
[Music]
who settled down
and forswore his
bad ways and is now coming back
right i mean
it's kind of a very interesting story
arc but um
but uh
you know but he's not
but none of that is obvious
at first right when you first meet
walter white it's not obvious what he's
going to turn into when you first meet
you know build money it's not obvious
what he's going to turn into
so
you know it's a i always found that
stuff to be very inspirational as far as
like developing a character and you know
taking them on that journey and how do
you how do you layer in stuff like that
you know and and build it out
but um and there are all sorts of tricks
and techniques to
how to define that
but um yeah i love that stuff